it's April but the award season 4 2015
games isn't over yet the British Academy
games awards took place last night and I
will be recapping all the deserving
winners from the event I'm Dave and
welcome to your gamespot news update
winner of artistic achievement was Orion
the blind forest beautiful platformer
from Microsoft and Moon Studios award
for audio achievement went to
everybody's gone to the rapture the
first person venture game developed by
the Chinese room also winning the award
for the music category Bethesda's
post-apocalyptic role-playing game
Fallout 4 took the award for best game
the event adding to their huge
collection of other awards winner of
Best British game was Warner Brothers
and Rocksteady's Batman Arkham Knight
the award for best debut game was
interactive movie videogame her story
written and directed by Sam Barlow the
award for best family genre went to the
insane rocket powered cars of huge
psionics hit rocket League the game also
snatching up the award for best
multiplayer game and best sports title
winner of best game design went to the
dark dreary and deeply challenging
action RPG blood-borne developed by from
software her story took a second award
recognized for its efforts in game
innovation and followed by a third in
the mobile and handheld category award
for best original property whence the
fantastic interactive drama survival
horror adventure supermassive games
until dawn introversion software's
prison architect locked away the award
for persistent game hi-rez Studios
action-packed third-person mobis might
won the award for amd's eSports audience
award and finally Square Enix and donut
entertainment took the award for story
with their episodic graphic adventure
life is strange additionally doom and
quake designer John Carmack will receive
a fellowship award at the show for being
a pioneer of 3d graphics this is the
highest honor that BAFTA gives out
individuals recognizing an outstanding
and exceptional contribution to film
television or games previous recipients
have included Shigeru Miyamoto will
write Peter Molyneux and gabe newell so
what do you think about this year's
winners what are your predictions for
the next year in games let us know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for all
your award-winning news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you